and one of our great presidents said if
you start a man in a race a hundred
years behind it is awfully difficult to
catch up so i don't think jordan
peterson is suffering from anything
except an exaggerated sense of
entitlement and resentment and his own
privilege is invisible to him and it's
manifest with lethal intensity and
ferocity right here on stage
[Applause]
jordan i'm going to have to let you
respond to that with me
well
what i derived from that
series of rebuttals let's say is twofold
the first is that
saying that the radical left goes too
far when they engage in violence is not
a sufficient response by any stretch of
the imagination because there are sets
of ideas in radical leftist thinking
that led to the catastrophes of the 20th
century and that was at the level of
idea not at the level of violent action
it's a very straightforward thing to say
you're against violence it's like being
against poverty it's like you know
generically speaking decent people are
against
poverty and violence doesn't address the
issue in the least
and with regards to my privilege or lack
thereof i mean i'm not making the case
that i haven't had advantages in my life
and disadvantages in my life like most
people you don't know anything about my
background or where i came from but it
doesn't matter to you because
fundamentally i'm a mean white man
that's a hell of a thing to say in a
debate
[Applause]
[Music]
let me let me just say very very brief
because i've got i want to move on to
men and women
the mean mad white comment was not
historical excavation of your past it's
based upon the evidence
which you speak in the denial of a sense
of equanimity among combatants in an
argument so i'm saying again you're a
mean mad white man and the viciousness
is evident okay
so i have a question do you think
there's money in racism there's money in
everything no capitalism sometimes i
think these people shoot
like sometimes i think these people
like him like i don't i don't know him i
like race hustlers yeah like they almost
do it for because okay for example
me i know if you say certain words on
the channel you get more views
there's like a particular audience like
like because i used to post more like
random stuff and my channel started to
blow up when i like stopped doing that
right and it was more talking about like
the problems of men and and there are a
lot of problems again and like stuff
that i really advocate for but sometimes
i think there are people that milk a
problem in order to make money off of
course that's what blm done yeah
that's what blm done it's like
racism sells to a particular demographic
just like feminism so particularly
like
you just gotta
understand your audience and i really do
think like a lot of these people just
understand they understand what they
want to hear yeah do you know what i
mean it's like if you put us in the
in the category of victims
we'll give you the money no that's what
and the more i get into media the more i
see it because there's some stats that
there's no way these people like don't
know
um so i'm not media people
okay like for example this this is more
of a feminism one but i'm sure there's
examples with race hustlers too but the
one i'm thinking of is the one in three
women where victims of a sexual assault
are graped yeah and like that's not true
it's not even close to i feel like that
statistic yeah yeah and it's not true
and there's no way they don't know that
it's not true
because
because they included people that like
if if i hooked up with someone and i was
drunk and he was drunk they included
that
oh
wow and what percentage of hookups are
when both the people are drunk
a freaking high ass percent i would
guess at least one in three
right
and like there's other research that
have said like most people most people
whenever having some kind of yeah that's
what like alcohol
[Music]
um casual hookups for the first time are
drunk
and so you're going to tell women that
we're victims in college if we were to
draw like what if i got too drunk and
robbed someone
no you got to prison yeah and so it's
like why is this like
just because he could be drunk too
and so they counted that they also
counted like if someone grabbed your
butt which okay that's not i don't like
that but that's happened to me i'm not
scarred like random people you know you
know like creepy ass guy like creepy
guys i get it that's weird that's
violent but i'm not i've had my ass yeah
like you're not you're not crying over
it like it's like oh that was weird but
then you just keep moving yeah or
getting cat called they they include
like all this stuff
but then that is assuming that women and
men think the same though
about that well i'm a woman and i'm
telling you like it is not i mean i
don't appreciate that but like it's you
should like you can't tell you can't
include that in one those statistics
though
that's what i'm saying yeah you can't
include that so they're clearly hustling
that because there's no way you're that
big and putting that in that big of a
platform
and not knowing that that's false same
with the wage gap why do they keep
pushing this this wage gap that doesn't
exist
like they have to know and i just i see
this and
with certain people when they like talk
like this it's just usually because they
don't have facts data or statistics to
back up their argument yeah i think
racehorses exist
i really do yeah and i think um
is that i said does racism exist do
racist racist people exist yes of course
yes
but to hustle it especially the way in
the way blm done it yeah like they out
hustled the black community with mit by
millions do you know what i mean and
it's just like
she's sitting there in her mansion like
not for much longer not if candice owens
has anything to do with it i love kids
okay um
so what'd you think of this video
have you seen it before
i've seen parts of it i haven't seen all
of it
um
i think
the emotional
arguments
when it comes to racism
always will get shot down if you don't
bring up statistics or something that is
factual et cetera et cetera if you start
to say you're a mean white woman do you
know what i mean i always do it's just
like okay because now you're just
attacking the person and not dealing
with the argument yeah so i think i
think they both made good points i don't
think it was a big enough segment for me
to get enough of what jordan peterson
had to say because i think michael dyson
definitely knows how to speak he just
kept going he definitely knows how to
speak so um
yeah it was cool like i said i think
i think these debates need to happen as
much as they like piss people off yeah
um
i think the more you speak about stuff
is the more you
i'm sorry the more you try to understand
the person's side
it's probably the place where you get to
like
that great area
which speaking of which guys we are
launching a new show called the gray
wonder i wonder why i wonder i don't
know why why would it be great i can't
think of a single reason it's just what
two colors make great it's a cool color
i don't know
um but it's gonna be tuesday at um 9
and yeah you guys should tune in and
watch it live
um i liked the video i thought it was a
good video i think
i'm i'm a die-hard jordan peterson fan
that is i'm like that is my number one
guy
so i'm always going to think he was
making yeah he was making points yeah
i like jordan peterson yeah i do believe
that
michael dyson is a little bit